those [ __ ] barrels well welcome back
to some Island
creepy hallway there we go
oh okay
sorry for [ __ ] pulsing hello run you
idiot this is not running this is
jogging alright alright we can't watch
this - no I don't understand what I did
that you know lack of bugs we so [ __ ]
much see that guy he's a dick I'm okay
okay I'm a dick but buddy [ __ ] okay okay
okay thing to think this you you haven't
think this blue man
you haven't think this through come on
sub chasing me where do I go oh oh oh
[ __ ] ah [ __ ] he's right behind me isn't
he is right behind me
but that's okay it's okay it's okay it's
okay it's okay that's okay we're gonna
go here
oh you oh good you're too fat fatty
fatty fat fat or what's the matter
oh oh just kidding never doing that [ __ ]
again okay listen let's just go inside
let's just go inside let's just go in
[ __ ] duck
okay of course that would have been too
easy wouldn't it gosh darn it oh bloody
hell
I want to swell - come on guys stay what
is this no batteries
then the man and then Adam and a bear -
bear - bear all right my dark instincts
are telling me to go here and we're
inside James Bond skills [ __ ]
all right but when I [ __ ]
nope you're beginning to understand not
really
oh good uh-huh yep okay I'm bored oh
right that way okay use the upper floors
to reach well listen that great how do
you get to the upper floors
oh I just hope that fat guy isn't
following me it's a fat guy following me
now well [ __ ] I like when fat guys
follow me it makes me feel like I'm a
little duck oh wait what what was that
it's real Otis we really need to save
the batteries money why would you knock
if I'm not gonna open I mean it's not a
metaphor for life hello there was nobody
there
or was it did you guys see something
what what hello
okay I'm coming in okay I get it it's
just yep
so much doin laundry sorry I don't mean
to interrupt but I just it's gonna offer
floors huh [ __ ] what about here whoa
your babies went over there I swear they
they they were over there
beautiful little ramen twins yeah
then okay um yeah that great talking to
you that's always good good talk
feel like we bonded all right
Stockton gosh gosh darn it it's like I
have the worst luck ever in this game ah
[ __ ] what was that oh oh oh oh what is
this back take them up take them it's
yours batteries mm - bear - but I own a
pair pair be all right where it is wait
Wayne this we're in this together really
well I ain't going on Mandy oh here no
all right why what about what do I do
jump is that what you say you think I
can make this jump y'all out ow
let's try this again yo to the hole to
the bro
[ __ ] yeah see that's why okay hello all
right
we're following the precip rooper the
hell are we
I was supposed to be here Oh like you
lit some candles and everything that is
one forgot about that little edgy thing
there hey it happens to that way why are
we here then Oh
the loading screen so we can't go back
I'm nearly hey yo gang man on it I hope
the girls I'm not gonna kill oh yeah oh
yeah this is why I ended episode isn't
it
oh yeah baby okay let me think
yes okay let me think genius Janie yes
genius
all right whatever evil and oh yeah we
needed the Fu's the tight space there's
no way that there's no way that fight
guy my belly hurts a little today I
think I'm pregnant
the fat guy is coming after us Gabe is
his name I named the mat right what is
this drive-in he nails I don't know what
a he nail is it sounds like a really one
of those punk bands I don't like a punk
yes I do god damn it
oh oh oh it's you hey how you doing
sorry don't mind me if I am I'll Drive
in done Nate oh it's a dirt oh cool bit
why is my heart beating this is a normal
Saturday for me what are you first thing
I do when I'm not recording this is not
a big deal mom and dad pile okay he can
see me
he can't see me oh my god please praise
Jesus
I'm a bad you check the other bed say
goodbye pick up yeah yeah yeah you go
your little snap it's new play you know
what
I can grab a stick and hit people too
that doesn't make me it right okay okay
we have 102 forces all right party it's
a party you're all invited
okay all right well we we got to find
more fuzes how many you sell per for a
bit but stupid text
I need the fuel cells don't think okay
maybe we need to maybe we need to go
maybe one of the battery then and then
and then and then in it maybe one of the
forces will unlock wanna I can't think
and talk it's very cool I like this
little design whatever all right let's
sit what were you doing in double
batteries and oh yeah okay one okay we
need two more five all right we can go
in here hi hi hi
all right I'm coming
what are those noises I'm expecting a
jump-scare I'm gonna hide in the locker
okay I'm bored
uh okay we can't go there so let's go
over here this does not make too much
noise okay we are in 1l we know a lot of
people adding hey hey hey yeah but you
don't see me do you
I am invincible I mean visible in yes oh
but an idiot I was right here hey will
thanks for covering for me bro you a
true man true man I love you well what
I'm not a wheel idiot
all right I'm a relay this all right we
have seven batteries I think we're OK
first time I started playing oh whoa
whoa whoa
everyone was like hey you were wasting
the batteries and I'm like no I'm not
look I have plenty all right just don't
it's the eyebrow man he left a note for
us oh it's just batteries and then and
then and then and then okay hi no we
don't need a hi we ain't no [ __ ] all
right double holy [ __ ] they're generous
more than Ellen more than all of them
all right there has to be invite the
vault no you're not invited
you're not invited to my party
[ __ ] you it's not invited to our party
you invited I'm invited only cool people
invited to put my party okay
all right cool come back on a bike the
wall right there you bet he pees on the
floor it's really awkward oh we got the
Foos oh I'm sure it's fine
invite Santa Claus yes Santa Claus is
invited indeed
okay you're not invited I keep telling
him all right well what are you doing
what is this
maybe okay fine fine if you promise not
to pee on the floor like last time
it smelled like like onions
it was weird okay gosh darn it why am i
doing it all right you're reminded that
you is invited is it coming I can tree
okay I'm not gonna risk anything all
right
we are Santa Claus
Am I am I gonna regret it
all right the walrider is here these
eyes are glowing
I don't know well what is he doing well
I can zoom
what is he doing
if she coming back I can't tell
this is weird
I'm not okay with this hello I invited
him okay
where did we come from it could be
anywhere
well that is [ __ ] creepy man did you
see that [ __ ] no this is scaring me Anna
like this alright pray for Revelation
Oprah Oprah Oprah [ __ ] what do i do need
to do aux or what
oh we [ __ ] up now I didn't see this
bed Oprah Oprah did you see this [ __ ]
hey you're not allowed say we cool we
cool right I'm just gonna take this hey
hi hey he went away why can't you go
away okay okay um that knife I am don't
like nice just gonna [ __ ] okay okay
you're not allowed here [ __ ] you think
about what you did son yeah that's right
okay we're not gonna wait up for it Oh
jab
bloody hell with this bum no okay okay
all right two of them bam bam
chef gasps ma'am give me the key give me
the key I don't have time for this myth
Yolo what am i down I'm sorry what the
[ __ ] day one for me I'm sick of you in
your [ __ ] do you understand doctor
pills bells toll and octopus-like the
pad typed up heads get up now get up now
talk all right we need to we need to
chill
we need a chair no I'm not
[ __ ] alright everything went better
than expected
okay we just have to go down and get the
keys and then go up a pop pop pop her
the top spin around it why do I know
this song tonight demon language okay
yep just gotta find the stairs no big
deal
they call it you call me the stair
finder in high school
anytime someone need to find this there
I was there man I was like it right over
there whoa whoa were you here before
dude you're [ __ ] creepy man jeez get
alive [ __ ] hell
all right why why we and stairs yes of
course the stance of course hide why
would I what is that clicking noise
the sinus a battery's neck mat foot
dosage and let's play oh come on
so much my reputation okay it's the
stairs the stairs the stairs has to be
somewhere
oh wait eight cow steak where is this
Terrace I'm losing my touch
man senses it says it oh come on jeez
alright let's go down to funky town
you [ __ ] stairs where are you alright
so it went down the elevator and drafted
my [ __ ] then yeah
now where the hell is that all right
Yolo it has to be here somewhere
um let me let me just think not there
yes not there no hmm
down here is it possible it fell all the
way down I don't want to be down here
again no no no no no no no I really
really really really don't want to be
here right now but what is this blinking
thing hello Halla batteries and the man
in nanana nanana
me what the [ __ ] is up I don't want
comfort that you're not anymore except I
don't actually read hello I guess people
like their privacy when they pee lesson
learned
all right that's an episode hope you
enjoyed as always you made it this far I
really appreciate if you leave a like
and it helps me out a lot and helps me
keep doing what I'm doing and hits the
sky recovering breath today and all